Next up, let's put some of these material instances into action.
So with this exercise, we're going to use a decal in order to animate an explosion.
So it will make more sense as we go on.
So to start off with, I'm just going to hit play to demonstrate what we've got.
It can take a second to render this in.
But if I now click on the world, you can see we have a very, very simple explosion here.
Now, let's make that look a little bit more fancy.
So I'm going to stop that.
Now, we already have our material and our material instance,
and we're going to be using a decal for this.
So let's open up our BP underscore targeting.
Drag that in, kill it down.
Now, you're going to see that this has a couple of things in it as part of it.
We have a decal as part of it, and we have a Niagara system.
And what this is going to do is have a nice tight function here.
It just says explode, let's then delay five seconds,
and then destroy the actor that we've just blown on.
But what we want to do is we're going to play around with this decal before.
So in order to do that, what we're going to do
is we're going to place a little bit of code before this.
We're going to add in a timeline.
So if I drag off of the begin play and type in timeline,
you'll see at the bottom here, we have an option to add timeline.
I'm going to left click on that.
I'm not going to bother renaming it, so I'll just leave it as timeline.
But the one thing that I will do is with a timeline,
a timeline will play for a certain period of time.
And during that, on every frame of the game,
it will execute any of the code which is connected to the update hit.
Now, this is where we're going to be doing the animation.
It's sort of going to be controlling the decal.
However, we don't want this to explode on every frame.
We only want that to happen after the timeline is finished.
So I'm going to hold down control.
I'm going to drag that string so that it plugs into the explode.
And then we're going to put our code onto the update him.
Right. So now I'm going to double click on the timeline.
And the first thing I'm going to do is change the length of the timeline.
So we can see at the top here, we have five seconds.
Let's change that to three.
So it's a bit faster.
And I'm going to add in a track.
So I'm going to hit plus, and this is going to give me some options.
We're going to do two tracks in total, but let's start with a float track.
So I'm going to take a float track, and I'm going to call this progress.
Now with this, I'm now going to add in two keys.
So to do that, I will right-hand click on here, and I'll go add a key to float.
I'm going to scroll out, and I'm going to add a key to the curve float at the end.
I'm going to move the end one a little bit below.
And the first one, I'm going to change this so that it is at time zero.
It's going to be value one.
If I push these two, it'll make it fit onto the screen.
So we've effectively got a line that's going down.
Now I will demonstrate this by just showing you the outside.
You'll now see that we have a progress output pin,
and this is going to provide us a float value on every tick update.
And it will be the value of where this curve is.
So if the time was at zero, it would provide the value of one.
If the time was at one second, it would be about 0.6.
If it was at two seconds, it's going to be about 0.2.5, and so on.
So this value will update on frame, and that's what we can use for the animation.
Now I want to do a second track, and for this I'm going to use a color.
So if I come up to add track, I'm going to select add color track.
And I'm just going to name this color.
Now this looks a little bit different to the other track here.
So you can see that we have a couple of different pins.
These pins can be moved around, and we can even change them.
Now the top pins is going to determine the color,
and the bottom pins are going to determine the alpha.
And these are usually used the alpha for transparency.
Now we are only really concerned about the top pins in this,
because we want the color of this decal to change from red to white.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to drag the white pin over to here.
I'm going to add a key here, double-click.
I'm going to make this entirely red.
So that will change that to entirely red.
I'm going to change the first one to entirely red as well.
So that way we have hit red until about halfway through.
Then it will slowly transition to white, and we'll have white.
This gives me a color which will update over time in the same way that our progress bar.
Now I'm going to go to my event graph, and I want to control the decal.
I want to control the material on the decal.
So what I'm going to do is you can see here we have a material instance.
Now it's worth seeing how we set this up,
because we want to set up something that's called a dynamic material instance.
We need to do this on construction script.
So this is the first point that anything is set.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to drag off of the construction script,
and I'm going to type in create dynamic material instance.
And you can see that we have the material here.
So if I was to double-click on the material, the countdown timer,
see that what we've got is we've got a circle which is coming into itself.
If I click on real time, you can see that it's moving here.
And now it's an animated circle that we're using to create the decal.
You can see that this is of the material domain decal.
So this is great.
We can use this countdown timer and create our material instance.
And we have a couple of values that we can control.
One of them is progress.
So you can see that is a parameter here.
And one of them is color.
Let's just spot that while we're here.
Here you go.
Circle color which defaults to red.
Those are the two ones we're going to control.
So we're creating a dynamic material instance.
Now this is interesting because before what we had was a static material instance
where you had to manually update the asset.
This is going to create a dynamic material instance just for this.
Now this isn't particularly performant because you have thousands of assets
which all have dynamic material instances on them.
They're all calculated in separate draw buckets or draw calls.
So they are a little bit costly.
But if you want to update stuff at runtime, this is probably your best option.
OK, so we have the dynamic material instance.
And what I'm going to do then is I will grab the timer
and I'm going to plug that in.
So we have a saved variable.
But the parent, we should also have to set the parent.
And if I search for countdown timer,
this is going to be the parent that we are going to create the dynamic material instance of.
Now what we need to do is we need to apply this.
So if I drag in the decal and I go set decal in material
and plug that in, and then plug that in there.
That means that we are creating a dynamic material.
Saving a reference so that we can update the variables on it later.
And then we're applying that material to the decal.
OK, so now we have our material.
Let's use our timeline to update it.
So I'm going back to our event graph.
And the code that we want to do is on the update section here.
So in order to do that, I'm going to drag in our material reference.
I'm going to get the timer.
And the first thing I'm going to do is set scalar parameter value.
And I'm going to plug that into the update here.
Now this is going to give me a couple of options.
It wants two inputs.
It wants the value and I can connect the value up to the progress.
And it wants the name of the parameter.
And so that is progress.
And we can see that here on the material.
Now the next thing I need to do is set the color.
So for this, I'm going to set the vector parameter value and plug that in.
Connect that up to the color here.
And the value that we want is circle color.
So there you go, circle color.
Again, we can check in the material.
You can see that we have circle color as a parameter here.
So on tick, it's going to use the timeline
in order to update the progress and the color of the value.
So if I was to compile and save now, let's test this and see if it works.
So I press play again.
And now we need to let the shader load.
You can see that we have a circle which is constricting into the center.
And then it's stuck.
So it gives us a kind of effect.
But all of these material is controlled by dynamic instance at runtime.
So that's just an example of one of the most common ways to dynamically use materials.
And it can be used for any of the inputs.
That you have in the material itself.